[Music]
all right everybody let's dip into the
world of social media before we go this
is what I'm
[Music]
liking all right the big game is this
Sunday and all week we are sharing great
stories to get you focused on football
because it's incredible as a Cowboys fan
it's not so incredible I'm still
devastated that we lost the wild card
game it's fine but this video put a
smile on my face and more than a smile I
laughed hysterically I almost peed my
pants a wife recorded her husband CU we
are these we I am this husband um a wife
recorded her husband watching that loss
and his reactions were so predictable
she created a bingo drinking game
marking the squares as he stressed out
take a
[Music]
look
this is my favorite what I'm liking
because I have never related more I
don't know if you can see it but my
favorite is the square that says
aggressively pets
dog which I have completely done to my
poor Henry I've been like oh my God like
with this it's got a lot of fur um we
have that couple on the line right now
everybody say hello to McKenzie and
Justin watching on nbc5 Dallas Fort
Worth what's up
y'all hi Callie um so does he act this
way for all games oh yes so um we've
been watching Cowboys games for together
for about seven years now and he's been
reacting the same way for seven years uh
you know he yells the same things he
uses the same gestures he sits in the
exact same spot and He even wears the
same exact thing every single game
because he is so superstitious yes um
and you know now I have learned to love
the Cowboys and be a Cowboys fan and
that's why I made this video card so
justtin you make your own clothing right
was that an outfit you made uh yeah I
actually made those shorts in college um
I I just made them as ridiculous as
possible I actually have them right here
um I look about I look about four feet
tall when I wear them and then we
actually have a one-year-old now and so
he got his own little pair yes these are
amazing oh my gosh so he uh yeah he gets
to uh join the very bitter Bittersweet
lifestyle of a Cowboys fan Cowboy Nation
yeah there we go um so he gets to watch
the uh the morning and afternoon games
with us and then uh for the nighttime
games I actually wear a pair of oven
mitts so I can clap without waking them
up oh my God I know cuz the box is say
quiet clap cuz anyone with kids knows
that it's like yeah oh oh my God I love
it so much it is so relatable thank you
so much McKenzie you're hilarious Justin
keep wearing those shorts or maybe don't
cuz they're not good look I don't know I
don't know let's just try something new
how about that cowboy Nation I'm loving
your post right now I'm liking it and
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of precise the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
sympathize with cowboy fans everywhere
so they will be riding you a check for
$1,000 there you go thank you so much
look Justin I'm going to keep wearing my
cowboy onesie you keep wearing your
shorts we're going to get there next
season next season
guys thank you to all our guests this
hour Dwayne Wade Callum Turner Jay
Shetty and lawren de yall have a great
game is not
[Music]
changing
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home